this is Startalk want to go to one more
tweet ah yeah let's do that so how about
there you go on some issues I'm a
staunch conservative like curtailing
greenhouse gas emissions so that we can
conserve the environment I get it mmm
cancer plus you work at that that kooky
American Museum of Natural History and
right there in the lobby is the statue
of our friend Teddy Roosevelt Teddy
Roosevelt an arch nature conservator so
he basically launched the whole movement
to save National Park I remind everybody
you know let's see what you will the
Environmental Protection Agency was
created under Richard Nixon who by many
standards is considered a conservative
president so too was NOAA National Ocean
we on the other side wonder how a
successful political party is gonna be
if it insists on eschewing the science
of germs and parasites as chewing
avoiding denying the science of climate
change I mean it's really an
extraordinary time to be not actually
this you're selling a book on this right
now yeah well next year no but it's
really an extraordinary thing that we
will be working on a book called
unbounded unbounded and I hope it's
gonna have the next great generation in
there okay there's kids today can dare I
say it change the world
so you and and and Tom Brokaw will lay
out the Great's of the great generation
of the next great just our parents my
parents fought in World War two and
there was deprivation and rationing and
there was innovation extraordinary
production and everybody was in it
together the music was about it this we
can do this everybody let's let's change
the world you've been listening to
Startalk the how tweeted is part the how
tweeted is section of the show you've
been listening to star talk the how
tweet it is part of it
bill thanks for being on you always
trying to change the world one day when
you do it tell me we'll celebrate listen
things just start join the conversation
on Twitter at start
I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson as always
bidding you to keep looking up this is
Startalk